Shopping malls may just seem like clusters of stores but they're actually very delicate profit-making formulas.
The ideal place to settle a mall is a central wealthy
location with lots of traffic: close enough to attract locals, easily driven to from nearby towns, and for maximum profit - tourist
accessible. With everything planned just right a mall is far more fruitful than its
individual stores could ever be. But even then, the tides seem to be turning. How can even the perfect mall beat the price and
convenience of Amazon and the data seems to confirm
online shopping is on the rise while more and more malls are withering away
but graphs like this are misleading the mall is far from dying and
Amazon only confirms this before we get there we first need to understand what makes a mall unique
because malls are owned and managed by a single company their incentives are very different from an
individual store a group of small
Local stores is normally the perfect opportunity for a big corporation to come in and steal their business but
To the owner of a mall too much competition means fewer stores and less rent being made so they carefully pick renters that not only
cooperate but actually complement one another this is why malls tend to have a similar set of stores whether you're in
Washington or Wyoming well if there are malls in Wyoming each class of mall from the
5-star
To the less than glamorous has a standard meta deck of stores that have been proven to generate more profit together
regardless of where it's located
But the real heart of the mall are the anchor stores big department stores that draw in the crowds for everyone else you'd never drive
To a store specifically for
remote-controlled helicopters or seasonal moustache warmers but if one anchor store can lure you into the mall these other shops get your business - and
they're positioned on opposite ends of the building making you walk past
Everything else to get between them the goal of a drive-thru is to get you in and out as quickly as
possible but malls are just the opposite doing anything and everything to
Prolong your stay they want to satisfy your needs so well that it's always just easier to stay a little bit longer so
for every need on maslow's hierarchy
there's a convenient solution not ten steps away the food court fills you up
brave deputies stand guard friends keep you company and your purchases are
psychologically rewarded companies even seem to think they're providing some sort of profound civic duty we actually don't call them stores anymore
we call them town squares but there's an obvious problem with this strategy
more and more people can't or don't want to spend a lot of time shopping
It may take some time but the trend seems clear physical retail stores are dying and the internet will be the new way to shop
there's one big problem with this theory Amazon just bought the grocery store Whole Foods for 14 billion
Dollars if physical retail stores are soon to be a thing of the past?
why are companies like Amazon and Alibaba investing in them? Part of these deals is about getting data for the algorithms but nowhere near
14 billion dollars worth but if you take a closer look at which stores are closing you may notice a theme. These are
businesses that never
adapted they cross their fingers that this internet thing would be a fad and kept selling the exact products Amazon is great for
unless I need an HDMI cable this very instant i'm just going to buy one online and
Probably even save some money but the average shopper at Whole Foods has a thousand dollars of
Discretionary income to spend a month they want to pay for a premium experience
likewise everything in an Apple store could be sold online but they continue building newer shinier stores at great expense
Amazon sees this pattern too walk in stores aren't dying old outdated ones are so what does this mean for malls
the bad news is that many of these dying businesses are actually anchor stores for average middle-class malls
without a Macy's or JCPenney paying rent and attracting visitors many are in serious trouble
But higher end malls are doing better than ever the more expensive the store the more customers care about the
experience and the harder it is for the internet to replace as long as the upper class keeps growing upscale malls will only do better
And better so yes there are malls that are dying but malls as a thing aren't dying at all and neither is retail the best
way
To predict the future is to look at where big smart companies are putting their money and companies like
Amazon and Apple are clearly betting on walk-in retail being around for a long time so you should too
you
can shop this holiday season knowing the mall Santa will be back next year and with luck we may even be blessed with Paul Blart 3
this video is sponsored by Skillshare
Skillshare is a website and mobile app with full high quality video courses on all sorts of topics both fun and professional
Let me actually recommend two course topics first the Adobe apps I've wanted to learn after effects
For some time but the interface is just so needlessly complicated it's the same with Photoshop
Illustrator and all the others everything about these programs
seems designed to confuse you so it's really ideal to have someone explain them for you when I've gotten errors or had something weird happen
with an application I'm learning I've asked a skill share instructor and quickly gotten it answered another cool course I found is on
Calligraphy my penmanship is
Terrible and it's also just a fun skill to learn it took me about 30 seconds to find a good course for beginners and you
Can take them at whatever pace works for you the first 300 people to use this link will get two months to see if you
like it for free it really helps support this channel and if none of the
17,000 classes interest you you can leave at any time without paying a cent thanks again to Skillshare